hello and welcome to my talk about
uh understanding the relative strength
of qpf cdcl solvers
and qpf resolution which is a joint work
with
all of our stuff um
as i assume that not everyone might be
fully
informed about qpf solvers and qpf
resolution
uh i will just start my talk with some
basics to this topic and then i will go
on with
our results okay
so maybe we just start with a that
problem
uh okay well this is that problem we
have given the propositional formula phi
let's call it phi
and we just want to find out if phi is
satisfiable that means
uh if it has a satisfying assignment if
it has
a satisfying assignment we want to
return such a satisfying assignment and
if not if it is unsatisfiable then we
want to return
kind of a proof of unsatisfiability or
refutation
okay for
technical reasons we will assume that um
phi is in conjunctive normal form
or short c and f that means uh
c and f is just a conjunction of clauses
and the clause is just a
disjunction of literals okay so for
example
this is uh cnf which is obviously
unsatisfiable
okay and then such is just the set or
like the class of all
satisfiable cnfs okay
um this class is going to be
pretty hard because it is np complete
but nevertheless that solvers
practical set solvers are
pretty efficient in at least in
industrial instances so for example
in examples from artificial intelligence
for example
so there is a natural question namely
how strong are these subservies then or
can we
somehow measure their strength or can we
say
why some problems are hard for such
solvers and why
some are not
okay let's maybe explain some simple
sets over
so most of these that solvers are based
on the so-called
davis partner lokman loveland algorithm
or short dpl
so how does it work
um we have a cnf
as an input and
the tribute case would be that a
fire just contains an empty clause
then this whole formula is obviously
false and we can
return false so it means it is
unsatisfiable
if phi however is trivially true that
means we do not have any
clauses that means it's a kind of an
empty
conjunction then it's obviously
satisfiable with
any assignment so you can return true
which means satisfiable
okay and if this is not the case then we
can
do what we call unit propagation that
means we search for
unit clauses which only contains one
literal
so for example l the clause
which completes only l and in order to
satisfy this formula we have to set l to
one
okay and we just do this we set l21
and then we go on until we do not have
any more
unit clauses
okay when we do not have any more unit
clauses left
we can choose an unassigned literal x
and then we
just return in a recursive way
the case where we set x to 1
and x to zero now
let's say phi was unsatisfiable then it
is also unsatisfiable
under x equals one and under x equals
zero so we will return
zero or zero so false or
false um and if it is satisfiable then
at least one of these two cases where x
is one or x
zero has to be satisfiable
so this really returns a correct answer
okay the more
interesting and uh commonly more
used solver is however the the
conflict-driven clause learning of
short ctcl which you could say is just
an extension of epl
with that additionally makes use of
so-called clause learning and
non-chronological backtracking
so clause learning just means when we
somehow
get a conflict we will um we will
analyze this conflict and learn a new
clause
i will this is explained a little bit
more
details in the paper i won't do this
here
and then non-chronological chronological
backtracking just means
we do not have to backtrack to the last
decision
so here for example f
if x equals 1
doesn't didn't give us a
satisfying assignment then we backtrack
back to x equals zero
so this is chronologically like tracking
and we can do it also non-chronological
by backtracking to some arbitrary point
in the past okay both algorithms
rely on the theoretical proof system
resolution which i
explained later
but maybe explain how we can formalize
such a cdcl
proof okay so i haven't explained ctl
here but it's
it's basically dpl some extras
okay so this is the formalization you
could say
so we have three sequences
the first sequence is some sequence of
t's
and these t's are called ctcl trails
i will explain on the next page of
what these trails are and
from each trailer we can learn a clause
with our
learning with our clause learning
procedure
these are the c's
okay and to each c belongs a
pie which is just a sub proof a
resolution sub proof of this learned
clause
okay so we can extract this uh the sub
proof
directly um from the cloth learning
process
so what are these trails the trailer is
just a sequence of literals that
represents a cdcl run between two
restarts or backtracking steps
okay we could say that it looked like
the following
i distinguish between two kinds of
literals
namely the p literals and the d literals
so the p literals are just
literals well let's say
let's start with p letters the d
literals are just the decision literals
so if we go back to the dpl we have
made some decisions and here
our decisions are these d literals in
here
okay and these p's are
the literals which are propagated by
unit propagation that means
we need to have unit clauses with these
p's
okay so this basically is a trail
and it contains all information we need
for such a ctcl run
so this is one way in formalizing
such as cdcl or light also qcdcl
proof okay
let's explain what resolution is okay
so resolution is the underlying existing
system of
cdcl and it basically contains
a consists of only one inference rule
namely this one okay where we
can derive c or d from your x
and just e or x bar okay
so c and d are here clauses
and x is just a literal
and we can also formalize a resolution
proof pi
of some uh c and f5 which is just a
sequence of clauses
where each c is either an axiom that
means it's just a
clause in the the original formula
or it was derived via this inference
rule
okay and the cm is the empty clause then
pi is obviously a refutation
also if we go back here to this prove
the same is true for here if cm is
empty then also this one is in the
reputation
okay so what are the connections between
these sat solvers and these proof
systems
so as well now that we can um extract
resolution proofs out of the cdcl
and we can also extract three like
resolution proofs from dpl
we can even say that three like
resolution is equal and
equivalent to dpl but that's not uh very
important here
let's concentrate on cdcl because it's a
little bit more interesting
so how do we extract a resolution proof
from cdcl
well we just we have a proof like this
with these
three components we will just uh stick
together the subtrues p
pi 1 to pi m so for example
in pi m we need the clauses
let's say c m minus 1 then we we
use the the the proof pi m minus one and
so on so we just have to stick them
together and get a big proof or big
reputation of this whole
formula
okay
so we can extract resolution proofs from
cdcl that means
resolution uh simulates cdcl
that means we can analyze the sub
solvers at least
with the aid of proof complexity okay
maybe we do an example here
so there's this very popular cnf which
is called the pistonhold principle
php and consists of the following
clauses you can see it here
and basically this whole formula encodes
the statement
that we can put m pigeons into n holes
without putting two pigeons and one in
the same hole
and obviously if m is choosing to be
bigger than
n then this whole formula is
unsatisfiable
okay and it has proven that php
with m equals n and plus one needs
exponential size to resolution
refutations
okay and then obviously also each ccl
run
of this formula needs exponential time
so there's one possibility in finding
hard results for
ctcl or qccl
not solvers okay
now the question is what about the other
direction
so if we concentrate to on
cdcl can we somehow extract cdcl
runs out of a resolution refutation
okay and there was this result 10 years
ago
from people there's about and davis
and they found out that for each
resolution refutation pi
of the formula phi there is in fact a
cdcl run
of some polynomial size that refutes phi
okay that means these both systems are p
equivalent but there's one point you
have to consider
namely this cdcl model in here
contains many non-deterministic elements
so for example decision making
uh we just said that uh
we have to decide some literals if we go
back to gpl
we had this uh x which was just an
unassigned literal
and we did not specify how we
find this x or what x do we choose
so this is pretty much non-deterministic
and then here this decision making
depends on the refutation we have given
but if we go to the practice
the cdcl uses of course deterministic
procedures for
things like decision making or clause
learning so we can't really say that
choose any decision we have to specify
this
okay so here this results only holds for
this
partially non-deterministic um
[Music]
uh proof system
and uh two years ago
uh mark maniels had this result where
he proved that this deterministic cdcl
with some deterministic decision making
is in fact weaker than resolution
okay so we get this overview here we can
we can define a partially
non-deterministic proof system
which is p equivalent to resolution but
the deterministic one is
is uh really richer than a resolution
which is not surprising because
resolution itself is more uh did a
non-deterministic
proof system so it is not surprising
that
deterministic proof systems are weaker
okay so now what we want to do here is
we want to lift this whole problem to
the quantified level so we know what
happens in the
the such case and now we want to go to
the quantified case
okay so maybe let's start to explain
what is qbf solving
okay so what we do here is we consider
quantified cnfs
or qcnf's in short which is basically
just a cnf
with some prefix the prefix is just some
quantifiers which i will write as this
so we have extensional or universal
literals or variables
um and we will assume that
also for technical reasons uh that all
variables
are fully quantified that means we do
not have any
um any three variables in there
and we also assume that phi contains
no topological clauses because
otherwise yeah we will we will just
we will just delete them if we have some
of these
okay and now because our formula is
fully quantified
we can just um rewrite our
our aim to um we want to check if
phi is true or false so it's not even
we do not really want to know if it is
unsatisfiable or not
because it doesn't have any any free
variables
it is either true or false
okay and if it is false we want to
return the refutation
okay and this qpf problem is
is even harder than the the sat problem
because it could be a problem is proven
to p
to be a p space complete
but the same as in that solving
industrial instances can be solved
efficiently nevertheless so here we have
the same questions of
why are some formulas
easy or why are some formulas hard for
these qbf solvers
okay let's explain the underlying proof
system
which is here a q resolution the q
resolution is just an extension of
resolution which can handle qcnfs
okay and it consists of now two
insurance rules the first one is
resolution which is basically
the rule from the sub case
but here now the rest of the the pivot
x has to be existential
and we do not have to
create tautologies so if we have an l
and c
then the negative of l
um is not allowed to be in d
and then we have a reduction rule where
we can handle the universal literals
where we say that if
we have a literal u in a clause and
left and right of u
is non uh
existential literal it's not any so
let's say uh
we have a literal you and each literal
which is la
we're just right of you in this clause
is only
universal then we can reduce this u
okay and we can even
um even more extend this q resolution
system
to and to a stronger system which is
called long distance q resolution
where we are now allowed to create
tautologies i will
not explain this here but uh keep in
mind that
we can also do this which was introduced
by xiang in malik 2002
and as resolution also cdcl can be
lifted to the qbf level
which is now called qbfcdcl or qctcl
okay and it was proven that we can
extract long-distance pure resolution
refutations out of negative
qcd cell runs okay as you see here
okay now the question uh can we gain a
similar equivalence as in the sub
case
well there was this russell from
yanotaha from 2016
which says the deterministic of the
practical
version of qctcl is really weaker
than q resolution
um but we could ask the question okay i
mean
in that case it's uh it's it's the same
because the deterministic version is
pretty weak can we
at least construct a partially
non-deterministic
stronger qcd-cell proof system which can
simulate true resolution refutations
and there we have to say that well
the original qctcl and q resolution are
incomparable
even when we take the non-deterministic
version of qcdcl
or the partially non-definitive version
there are separations in both directions
okay so let's make an overview of our
results
here so in qpf we have a more complex
picture
so qcdcl is really incomparable to q
resolution
but what we did was we designed a new
qctl model we which we would call a
qcdcl
a searching order no reduction is
we will explain this in the paper a
little bit more
in detail which is
equivalent to q resolution okay and
then we get this over here
so let's make an example of this
separation so i said we can separate
we can separate qct cell and q
resolution
okay in the first direction can be done
with the so called two parity formulas
uh so the comparative formula consists
of these
those prefix and of these clauses here
as you can see
and um basically you could say that each
of these tis
encodes the partial sum of the
x from x i one to x i
okay and the whole formula then encodes
the statement that
the whole sum of these x are
uh 0 and 1 which is obviously not
possible
so this call okay whole thing is also
false and
we can really write down a polynomial
sized
qcdcl refutation of q parity
which i will not do here because it's a
little bit ugly and bulky
but you can do this okay but on the
other
side one can prove that q parity really
needs
exponential size q resolution
refutations
okay so this is one direction the other
direction can be done with
um the help of these pigeonhole
principles from the beginning
so then we can construct these
formula which we called tractor
which basically consists of um
a propositionally hard part
and an easy part so the first
clauses in here which are the pigeonhole
clauses are pretty hard
to refute and the rest of this is just
some easy stuff
okay
and you can prove that this triple
formula
needs exponential size cures or qcd cell
refutations
but there are constant sized you could
also say polynomial size
q resolution reputations of trapdoor
okay
and now we want to though now we have
separated these q resolution and qsvcl
but now we want to design a new uh
new system new procedure of qctl
that is equivalent to q resolution
so we have to modify this qcd cell a
little bit
in order to gain something equivalent
and this modification has to be
um incomparable because yeah well
the the original systems are
incomparable so it's not enough
to just strengthen the system
and what we do is we use uh so-called
policies to modify
this model so we use
decision policies which just tell us
what decision we are allowed
to make okay so um
yeah we specify rules and decision
making it is still a little bit
non-deterministic so it's not
fully deterministic but yeah
it's still enough and then we have
reduction policies
which tells us how we handle reductions
in unit propagations okay so we are
in um in the qpf case also unit
propagations
can make use of reduction
and in our new model we just say that we
do not allow any
reduction in the process of unit
propagation
and we also use the new decision policy
asserting order which i will not explain
here because
it's a little bit technical but
basically it's um it's a more liberal
system or no more liberal policy than
we had before okay and now our result
here is just um
for each q resolution reputation pi
there is a refutation
um in our new system qctcl
searching order no reduction
of also polynomial size so these both
systems are
p equivalent
and then we get this whole overview so i
said dpl is not so important
cdcl is equivalent to resolution
then qctcl is incomparable to
incomparable to q resolution
then we have the connection between
qcdcl and long distance q resolution
where we can
at least extract here at a long distance
q resolution proofs
out of the algorithm and now we have
this new model
so this new qcdcl system which is really
equivalent to
q resolution
okay so let's summarize what we did
so far so um
in the sub case we have seen that
uh practical and deterministic cdcl is
in fact weaker than the underlying
proof system resolution but
the partially non-deterministic model is
equivalent
okay so we get this overview and
then again the qpf case it's a little
bit more complex
um qdcl qcdcl is incomparable to q
resolution even in the non-deterministic
case and um
we have to modify this qcdcrm model a
little bit
and then this new model is really
equivalent to
q resolution and we get this
okay with this i will
end my talk and yeah thanks for
listening